[Music]
prime minister justin trudeau touched
down in munich on a sunny sunday morning
was greeted by a traditional bavarian
hunting party and band then took off in
a helicopter for a castle in elmau in
the bavarian alps a summit with g7 and
other world leaders where the dominant
topic of discussion will be russia's
invasion of ukraine and all the global
turmoil that has caused lots of hard
work to do on climate change on ukraine
and on and on growing the economy and
helping our citizens
the key objective for trudeau and all
leaders here maintaining the unity and
resolve of the g7 in support of ukraine
we have to stay together
because putin has been counting on from
the beginning
and somehow nato would
and the g7 would
splinter and
but we haven't and we're not going to
good messages that we all made to stay
united
but protesters insist climate change
must also be at the top of the g7 agenda
and leaders here will indeed spend time
talking about that tackling climate
change is both a challenge and a massive
opportunity
on climate the eu is the leader and we
are fully committed to the paris
agreement still with those fresh rocket
attacks on kiev sunday ukraine remains
the most urgent topic on the table here
right now and on monday the ukrainian
president himself will join in vladimir
zelinski will dial in by video
conference to talk to justin trudeau and
other g7 leaders about what more the g7
can do to support ukraine in its war
against russia